I remember sending in for my application
to Stanford a 50-page dialogue I had
written for no reason
it was just like something I did on a
Saturday between Plato and Socrates and
I imagined like how they would try to
one-up each other that's funny I
actually have this weird feeling that I
the reason I wrote for economic DC's was
not because I love economics because I
think I love to write yes and the end of
the summer I borrowed a typewriter from
another friend and I typed up the novel
that had been hand writing and I got
about 3/4 away through typing it when I
realized it sucks it's terrible I'm no
writer then one day I finally my writing
didn't suck
you have to write four hours a day for
seven years yeah to get any good at it
yeah should I have a comma or not I have
a comment show you use this word I just
like I'm just getting it's it's such a
perfectionist art learning to push
through periods of imitation to finding
your original sort of voice like when I
started in publishing in 1989 there were
50,000 books coming out of here by time
I left in 95 is 80,000 was easily over a
hundred thousand and now it's well over
300 thousand I got a year it was also
interesting to go back and look at the
60s globally this is just in the u.s.
that's in the US I sold my first novel
and to Random House satire is humor sent
on a moral mission and I was like why
doesn't anyone write shot are so I wrote
a very dark satirical novel about how
Wall Street was destroying the world
called bomba deers
it was a filthy profession but the money
was addicting and they were all going to
hell we started the grotto and we
dreamed of a day that it could be a
bigger thing and we're now going into
our 23rd year we have 125 writers at
second and Bryant yeah and three classes
a night and the writers can make money
teaching which is great for them you
can't be addicted to these devices and
right now
no you think yeah they don't work at the
same time no the best writing I've ever
had in my life was at the 10-day
meditation retreat yeah so the first
novel I wrote I wrote it in a closet and
that first closet was literally three
feet long and two feet wide and I
actually found nonfiction to be told to
my surprise uh uh but um naive person I
was as really interesting a creative
challenge as anything because you have
this constraint yeah which is that you
have to tell the truth and then what I
do in life was about telling people to
get on to a more meaningful life by more
meaningful things you can do with your
work you know listen to that voice you
have and follow it and be doing the
right things in this world some kids
some people need stress perform their
best is based on how their brain works
and other people do not perform best
under stress they need a less stressful
mom to inform their cognitive best and
any sort of testing of any sort is gonna
bias one population
he was basically gave me a warning that
like your creativity and your prolific
Ness the enemy of that the thing that
will steal it is you get older it's not
your age your mind is not it it's not
any different your mind is anything just
gets sharper and sharper and better but
it's distractions it's distractions and
it's distractions which manifests it in
a thousand emails a day yup it
manifested people calling you it's
manifested in someone becoming sort of
popular or well-known suddenly everyone
wants you to speak or do this or do that
[Music]